Film Courage: Joe are you from LA? Joe Wilson,
Screenwriter/Filmmaker/Author: I am not. I'm
originally from Poughkeepsie, New York-ish area
and then I lived in Boston for 13 years and then
got a call from a production company out here who
saw a newspaper review of a show I did in Boston
and that sort of got the ball rolling to come out
and hey let's make money out here as opposed
to really never making money in Boston ever
like breaking even was the goal for those shows.
Film Courage: May I ask what year this was? Joe:
We moved here in '97. 97 okay twenty two years
ish era yes exactly exactly okay yeah and i was on
i was online really early i did the cleveland
performance art fest i was a performance artist
and a visual artist for before i started doing
all this stuff and a photographer before that
so long i have a weird resume i did the cleveland
performance art festival in 1995 and the way they
described me was i was an internet surfer i was
like joe wilson performance artist internet surfer
and just like now we're all internet surfers now
that is not like at that point that literally was
such a different thing to do that people would
note it and had a word for it because it was not
the norm and really not until the phones came in
and normalized everybody had a computer they just
called it a phone and that changed behavior
and and i think that changed behavior to
you know david lynch hates that people watch
movies on their phone but a lot of people watch
movies on their phone and now they're making them
on their phones too so i i think it's a good thing
what did you love about los
angeles when you first moved here
uh potential i guess it was i i came here and was
head down and had a five-year plan and if things
weren't working in five years i was pulling out
and i literally got married moved here two weeks
afterwards and i was writing i was doing stand-up
i was acting i was taking acting classes and
improv classes and writing classes and at some
point i felt really spread thin and i stopped
doing stand-up for a while and really focused on
screenwriting because i kind of felt like that was
probably what i was going to end up doing it
seemed like the thing that fit well because acting
acting is a lot of fun but acting and crappy
stuff is not and auditioning for crappy stuff is
even less fun and uh so when things stop being
fun and you're not making any money doing them
then you start to question why you're doing them
and so i really honed in on writing for a while
and then i started doing stand-up again i never
really went back to acting i may have done a
couple of things because people have asked me to
do stuff but i don't consider myself an actor i
do have the ability to pretend professionally i've
been paid so sag after has one of those things on
file for me but i don't you know i did a pilot in
a couple of commercials and i think what i did was
uh in retrospect i'm on my fifth to fifth
five year plan and uh and they've never worked
they've never worked all five year plans
are i mean it's a nice to look at a chunk
of time and say you know this is going
to be done by this but bird's eye view
now that i've seen like 22 years click buy the
open mic that i went to when i first moved here
those are the relationships that
turned into business literally like 15
20 years later uh because of relationships
that happened there and i think when you're
when you're all low on the totem pole you consider
everyone else low on the totem pole because you're
low on the totem pole and you don't realize oh
wow this is you know it's hard to figure out
who to collaborate with because you're trying to
find the right personality but uh that is where
you know i know people for all that time and
i know that's when that's when the connections
were made and that's when you know you want to
work with people you like people you know and
so if you know people and they get a gig
they tend to bring in people that they know
which is nice i've had it happen a couple of times
well from having interviewed you in 2012 and 2013
i am not going to call you the c word which
i had called you before and that is content
creator yeah sorry yeah yeah not the other
day yeah yeah that'll call you off the air so
you're kidding okay but um so with the five year
plan the first one what was then the backup if
that didn't work uh there wasn't a backup you
just knew that the initial five-year period
well i just looked at it as if if i didn't see
any indication that i wasn't out of my mind trying
to do this stuff then um i would keep going and
there was always enough i got a pilot in two years
um so thing you know i got a comedy central
national um stand-up contest in like the third
year i was here so stuff stuff really happened
really quick uh and then stuff didn't happen for
a long time and then stuff happened again and uh i
listened to a lot of bad advice um i think i spent
i sort of looked at the entertainment industry
like well if i'm a good student and of the
industry and i you know read all the trades
and know all the stuff that's going on and and
that that somehow would make me better as a
property as a an entity to sell as a writer and
it was a complete waste of time just just because
i know how to you know what ankling means doesn't
mean that reading variety is a good use of
time um especially at this point in history
you know back then it was it was you know
came out five days a week it was thick it
was there was a ton of information in it now
it's like once a week and it's like a pamphlet
and it doesn't matter you know a lot of things
matter less now because there is so much to watch
there has never been this much to watch
and there will never be less than right now
who was the bad advice from bad advice was from
other comedians other actors other
people in improv classes teachers
mentors losing a word loosely i think what it
is that you tell yourself how it's going to be
and so when things start to happen like like
you've heard other people's careers happen like
uh i was i was in the uh uh write it respect
screenplay uh get in a contest get a manager
sell it that was it that was the whole
plan and uh so i did that a couple times
and had people tell me i was gonna be a
millionaire and very nice to have people tell
you who have made other people millionaires that
you're going to be a millionaire it's very nice
especially when you're writing stuff that is
to sell it was written to sell high concept
comedies the elevator pitch that you only
need half the elevator ride to pitch it like
it's that kind of quick stuff and that's what i
was focusing on and i i wasn't i guess i wasn't
acclimated to the rough ride that was coming i
didn't realize how much people would lie to me
uh people who represented me people who i worked
with people i collaborated with uh just wow
there's definitely that element here which
is i think a surprise to a lot of people that
aren't from here you know it doesn't surprise
me i just i exp my expectation is that
when someone represents themselves as something
especially because you know when you first move
here you're so impressed with people's
resumes you know if they've done anything
they know more than you and the problem is is
that maybe they just got lucky and they're full
of [ __ ] and they don't know anything they're
just blah blah blah blah and they happen to teach
a workshop that you can pay for and and then you
realize oh so that resume thing that they have
that was really the only thing that they've ever
had and they've been cashing in on that thing
doing these workshops acting improv writing
screenwriting whatever and i understand people
want to make money and people have information
but that there is a dark side to that uh and it
you know at some point i hit i hit the wall
i was just so sick of me working my ass off
to hear now again you know at some point you're
like all right so i'm gonna work my day job all
day which i was a private investigator working at
home so i had one desk and i'm working all day and
then day's over and then i go over to another desk
and i'll bring a screenplay and then i go back to
work and so do that for i don't know years and at
some point you start to think wow so this is my
life right now and it's going right by and all i'm
doing is [ __ ] typing here here's another one no
okay this is great oh this is the best i'm writing
stories that are going to make people laugh and
oh no i'm not i'm just filling up hard drives
with a bunch of [ __ ] bites no one's ever going
to see the screenplays they will die like most
screenplays that's what happens and i think the
the thing that i am glad i came to the conclusion
was i didn't i just wanted to [ __ ] make
something i was so sick of just like why does
someone have to give me permission and the
thing that that uh uh anger is an energy uh it's a
public uh image limited song and it made me angry
that i i wrote three short screenplays and all
of them were shot by people who two of them had
gone to film like good film schools and they were
um garbage they were garbage and i was just like
i just wrote three shorts for you people to make
and oh my god this stuff is garbage i'm gonna have
to learn how to direct now great i didn't want to
direct i just knew the only way that i'm going to
have any ability to get the tone of this comedy
where it needs to be is for me to be in the room
controlling that tone because they
don't get it on the paper they hear
they hear your head you're handing them
heavy metal and they're giving you back poca
and you're like you know i just gave you [ __ ] i
worked my ass off for you for this heavy metal and
you're handing me back this doo-da-doo crap and
it sounds like [ __ ] and that dialogue is music
comedy is music it's you know drama comedy that
dialogue there is it just it has a timing it has a
uh an effect it's it's and when someone else [
__ ] it up and then i had to learn to edit and i
had to learn to shoot and i'd learn to mix sound i
learned to do little special effects and i learned
to work with fight choreographers and produce
and all the post-production because if i knew
how to do all i wouldn't have to count on anybody
so i got it down to all i need is actors i can do
literally every other job i have shot there's
a short i made called clyde hates bonnie that
i shot solo i'm the only camera person i'm the
director i'm the camera person we worked with a
choreographer we had two rehearsals two two fight
rehearsals and uh only time i ever storyboarded
and i uh and it worked like i was amazed
like i always think we got to have you know
you can have people and all the people
and now you don't need all the people
you don't need all the people really break
it down what do you need well i need a
camera and sound and light and an actor right
there's nothing else i need it's pretty simple
that and some place to shoot once you
have all that then you can shoot anything
do you really think people were lying to you
in the beginning or were they saying these
things that were sort of the catchphrase at the
moment oh the gatekeepers and you you know and
and that was like trendy back in like 2010 2013
and then there's a new way to do it and then a
new way oh yeah there's always a new way and
there's always a new story and that never ends
i know for a fact that i was lied to on a
number of occasions by individuals and it
sometimes it was milds the information and
sometimes it was information that if i had
uh would have been uh less catastrophic why did
they lie to you uh they were afraid of the truth
and they were the one that had to deliver
it and they didn't have the guts so
i had to find out through other means and
uh and that was after years of collaboration
you know how they say in storytelling
there's like these tricksters
shape-shifters whatever do you think some of them
were those or no i think they're just [ __ ] okay
it's it's the brand the type of the the
level of entitlement that happens in los
angeles is a different brand of entitlement
that happens in anywhere else other than
maybe you know parts of new york city parts
of paris part to london but la's got a big
mass of just people who have arrived here
waiting for someone to know who they are
and i've i've been in super successful
realms and i've been in super not successful
realms with people and like i worked with
michael j fox and a sitcom and tracy pollen
they were the nicest human beings i was i was
kind of like you're so nice like i'm i've got like
nothing i'm a nothing part i got two scenes and
i'd do nothing in those scenes and he came up to
me he was like hi i'm mike fox and i was just
like no you're michael j fox and you just said
your name wrong and and then a week after we
shot the oddly we shot the pilot in november
he announced he had parkinson's and you could not
see it you did not know it and the idea was that
he was going to produce it and she was going
to be on camera and he was going to be slowly
moving away from them and it didn't get picked
up telling stories has been fun for you working
in the entertainment industry not so fun i think
that was a quote from you somewhere yeah i think
at some point when you're banging your head
against the wall and you're trying and that
and that is i mean that is a career that
is what you do if you want to be successful
you keep writing and you keep banging your
head against that wall until something goes
the thing that crossed my mind because i
had some friends die young was that i was
relatively young and was i going to die typing and
not making anything like all i want like i made
i wrote to have three shorts made because
i just wanted to have something made
like just well i'm typing i just want to see
this happen and then when i saw it happen like
i literally could not go to the screening because
i was so angry at how bad everything was and and
so i i think at some point i was just like
literally like [ __ ] this why am i doing
this what this has been years and i have
gone through managers and ups and downs and
projects that were going to be huge and and not
you know little tiny things happen but not enough
for a career not enough to you know you you all
you're doing is stringing together a bunch of
temp jobs that is what the entertainment industry
is it is a bunch of temp jobs yeah maybe you get
lucky enough to be on a show that lasts for years
but most of the time these are temp jobs you're
working one day maybe a week maybe a few months
and then there's no work and sometimes you have
a great gig and you make a ton of money and then
nothing happens ever again and that is a reality
that happens no one wants to talk about it because
no one wants to hear you know there's this really
good possibility you're going to spend all your
time and all your life and all this time nothing's
going to happen and you're and that's it and
you're going to look back and you're going to
think hey that was a lot of money that was a lot
of time wow so that was my life huh interesting
maybe maybe i want to change
things up a little bit and
the most fun i had was when i said [ __ ] it the
most fun i had that's when things started going
together that's when things started just it seemed
effortless when i stopped looking for people
to say yes to a script when i was just
like i'm making this do you want to help
changes everything and then when you make
something and it doesn't suck and then you
can use that to make something else and then that
doesn't suck and then you use that and you can
then you're slowly building these little tiny
increments until you have a couple hours online
of a bunch of stuff you've made and then it exists
and people see it and it doesn't disappear and
what's amazing and the thing that you do not know
when you make anything online is stuff that i made
in 06 i got a comment on last week oh wow so
that's the thing that nobody tells you like
this youtube's not going anywhere it's not
going and there and as far as i know they're
not cleaning out the old stuff so if you have
your short up there yeah maybe it doesn't have
20 billion views maybe it didn't go viral maybe
whatever maybe just maybe it doesn't suck maybe it
will entertain amuse whatever someone why did you
start to do this to begin with and i started to do
this because i was like i love when i'm sitting
down and something happens on a screen or on a
stage and i and it makes me feel different i want
to be able to create that how do i do that spend
[ __ ] decades typing and stand up and acting
and like going to school for photography really
came in handy when i was a director because
all of a sudden all of a sudden the the slr
was a video camera and i'm like yeah i know that
all these numbers have had to memorize forever
like i can i can tell everybody what f-stop
to go to because i knew it when i was 11.
like so it made all this stuff really easy you
know i knew focal lengths and all that stuff none
of it i knew the shape of 35 millimeter because
i had been taking pictures and trying to fit the
world in that so i had i was one up on everybody
i didn't need a director of photography because
they'd taken so many great pictures because i
spent years learning how to do it so now i'm just
making ones that move that's why i never went
tripod because i'm like i want to be able to
get whatever i want whenever i want it i do not
want to try pot around it's too slow it's too
slow i want three cameras two operators here i'm
operating boom cover cover cover cover cover next
did your parents like their jobs you know yeah
my father i think i did for
to some degree and i think
my mother tolerated it i guess they both came
from poor backgrounds and my father was a
construction worked in construction as a plumber
union uh down austin area and my mother worked on
an assembly line for ibm and then worked
her way up to be a cat operator and then
both of them got screwed over they
forced everybody into retirement
and then hired people back as temps to
to train their replacements oh wonderful
and then the the union was starting to run out of
money and started cutting off you know uh benefits
and stuff so i think when i saw them get screwed
i was just like i'm not gonna work my ass off so
so i can be a cog in somebody else's machine
just that is the one great thing that came from
my parents going like they did all the right
things american dream high school educated
family we all went to college house they
did everything right still got screwed
so i didn't want to do that so do you think that's
what kind of like lit a fire under you to say okay
i'm gonna go from wherever to boston do some stuff
okay then i'm gonna take this chance this person
communicated with me said come to la and so you
knew that that's not the life for joe wilson
i i'm not going to be doing that i'm not going to
work for some company and then being politely or
not so politely pushed out the door yeah that was
the goal i did end up working for a company for
11 years that i own a little tiny piece of that
was started by writers and actors that's still
in business um so it's not like i'm against you
know i'm not like damn the corporations i just
know what happens to companies when they get big
when companies get big they care less about people
they you know when ford had the pinto in the
70s and when people hit it and it blew up
ford said well we can either recall and pay for
that or we can just pay for all the lawsuits
and they chose the lawsuits and they're still
in business amazing i have one of their cars so
do you ever go back and say well i know
i'm typing at this one desk and here i'm
wearing this one metaphorical hat as this
job and then i'm turning around and i'm
typing at this other desk as a quote
creative storyteller even if i don't
make a million dollars right away or in the next
20 years i still got to do this or ever i still
want to do this because this is who i am and i
can't stop telling stories and i don't want to
have a job that i hate that i have to go
to and i have to smile at people and make
it seem like i want to be there and i don't
really want to be there and my boss is an
idiot and i'm having meetings about meetings but
i didn't do this screenwriting so i've given up
i think there's a question
sorry i
um i don't know say that well i
guess my question with all that
gibbering jabbering that i'm doing is like even if
there isn't hollywood putting a stamp even though
people love vampire mob and it has views and
people gave you feedback yeah sure if you want
to do a second version of something right but
no because hollywood said they didn't want me so
put it right i'm not touching that again is that
where you're at i guess i got there years ago to
not acknowledge the entertainment industry to kind
of like if i if i could make something without it
then and the end result it was it was sort
of like i needed to get to the audience
and the thing that was between me and the
audience was all the companies that make
the [ __ ] to show to the audience so if
i could find some way to get around them
and get to the audience which social
media allowed um you know and i've
i've had people and continue to have people find
stuff and and like stuff and you know you make
somebody laugh when they're having a bad day
or a bad life or a bad you know time and i know
my wife was diagnosed with cancer a few years
ago and i know how much comedy really can help
like i have seen it firsthand so there's a value
in in making stories you know whether it's drama
or comedy or whatever the genre but i think you
know now because there's i think the number of
guest star performances to be considered for
emmys was 2 800 and something performances
so if you have that many
potential nominees for for guests
when you have thousands of performances and you
have thousands you literally there are more shows
than anyone can get to in their lifetime
if they wanted to do it full-time and just
watched television they couldn't get to it all
so now i'm making more stuff for them to watch
why why am i going to make something that i
have to be in the same boat that netflix and
everyone else is like how do you get all these
how do you get that much attention like everyone
is so twitter facebook instagram snapchat what i
gotta watch something what oh there's something
right yeah music how do you get their attention
they i think if you're going to be indie that you
have to spend years getting to know your audience
and talking to and i and i have changed my term
a little bit in terms of audience because now
i i see the people i know online as neighbors
because i talk to them all the time you don't
talk to audience all the time audience is this
thing that's over there and you're over here
and and i think a lot of people like that
a lot of people like hey i'm over here you're over
there i act you stay over there i'm a director
you stay over there when you talk to people every
day because you're not making everything all the
time like you i don't care how good of a producer
or you're not putting out movies all the time as
an indie person so there's going to be all this
time that you're not going to have something new
and if you're spending all your time on
social media talking about your [ __ ] project
jesus christ really more tell us more you
typed another page yay come on that is not
i i know what interests you and i know it's a
great thing for you but you're just typing you
know you finished a screenplay okay i'll give you
that but i i did another thousand words shut up
tell me about the thousand words after you've
done fifty thousand and then a hundred thousand
and then three hundred thousand then maybe
you talk about the words a little bit but
just because you typed all november to get to get
a novel out doesn't mean you made anything good
it just means you typed every day uh i don't
know what that tangent was about that's okay
i enjoyed it oh good i'm glad know there was
a point to this therapeutics the i think the
a story can have a value without the entertainment
industry and the entertainment industry doesn't
value stories they value profit uh the marvel
universe is a very big complicated story but that
is something that has an audience that was built
in for decades and you only market at a level
that is saturation when you're playing with
literally billions of dollars but all that's for
other people that's not for me that's not for most
people that is that's the giant machine that is
you will be a cog in that
machine unless you're on screen
you will be because it's just too big and even if
you are on screen you're still really disposable
because that is disney has bought the world
and that is really valuable property right now
just like in um say anything and forgive me i'm
bringing on uh john cusack's character but he's
basically i don't want to you know produce
oh yeah you know buy anything that you know
i was talking her dad at dinner right right right
aren't we all sort of owned by somebody though
i don't care if we work for marvel and oh yeah
yeah and we're and they want your picture or sure
you're working for a company yeah you
got to work you have to work for somebody
yeah we all like to own an online reselling
business to sell stuff to make money that way
so all of my customers are technically my balls
sure sure uh i don't think nor do i expect what
i make to generate enough income for me to live on
what i do online it's more it's just like anything
else it's a gig it's just a little gig you do
something maybe make a tiny little bit of money
and then gotta put another one together and
another one together and uh i was on a roll
when my wife had cancer that
roll the wind and the sails
stopped and storytelling was not important anymore
and was not a priority and was not anything that
i thought about for a long time because i had
other stuff that was more important and i think
i think the other thing about this is
that sometimes and i've seen people do it
to their demise literally sometimes people
make the entertainment industry and success in
it more important than anything else including
other people and at some point you're going to
end up being an empty shell of a human
being at the other end of it and you will
maybe you won't regret it but man you're
going to be bitter as hell because it's just
when when when the the socializing
in los angeles is based on perceived
success whether it's current recent or
about to happen and people i've had the
and it's the classic thing you're at the party
and someone's talking to you but they're like
and that person's way more important i really need
to go talk to that person but yeah yeah yeah i'll
be here with you and then they go talk to that
person or or the classic hey you're going to come
to my show now when is that uh no is it already if
i show up late oh no you know i think i have this
thing you know i'll try to be there okay that's in
la that's an la definitely you're definitely going
to be there then i'm definitely probably trying
to maybe be there yeah maybe but i'll but i'll try
thank you they're not showing up i remember
when i was doing stand-up comedy everybody
was doing one-man shows or one for solo
shows so everybody was just trading off
everybody's just going to each other's
shows because we needed an audience and
because there's just so many comedians and
there was so little audience in los angeles
well it's gotten that way with crowdfunding it's
like you want to donate to people's campaigns
but after a while we just had another guest that
reminded me of that and that's a great point that
you want to be able to give to these campaigns
over and over again but you've already given to
so many and you're kind of like tapped out and
i think that's that's part of the problem but
going back to storytelling do you plan on
giving up storytelling no no no no no i
when i was doing vampire mob i uh one of
the cast members marshall wallace died
and i had written a whole season three and uh
the idea of trying to make it without her seems
weird like i easily could have written her out
i easily could have cast someone else and it
was just kind of like this isn't i don't know it
just didn't feel right so i went graphic novel
i went comic book and i don't know anything about
comic books i didn't grow up reading comic books
i'm not a comic book guy so then i had to learn
about comic books learn how to write comic books
and man i wish i had done that like before i ever
took a screenwriting class because for you to have
so i'm adapting a screenplay into a comic book
so i have it all written but it can't just get
dropped it isn't like i'm just taking the script
and then oh look it's a storyboard with words
it's like you have to go through and like what are
the five panels that you're going to put on this
page that are going to tell the story and you're
going to have to leave most of it out because you
can't have this giant long thing because you want
to watch your character walk through the alley for
an hour you've gotta go so it changes how you
see story achieve now all of a sudden you think
oh i want this panel on this page to end so when
they turn the page and they see that top panel the
surprise will be there you're literally writing
like that there's no plot points it's page points
and the challenges with making a graphic
novel i just put an issue too to the printer
so the second issue will be coming out soonish the
challenge is working with artists getting artists
i can't draw the frustration to be honest
putting the two books together has resulted
in me writing a book so i am 45 000 words into
something called bob berry's things it was an
idea i had a couple of years ago and i just
needed something somewhere to go like i when
i'm writing i'm i disappear completely that's
the way i look at it i'm daydreaming on a page
writing is orchestrated daydreaming i'm
just daydreaming it's not hard to daydream
so it's really easy and i like it and now i've
spent it takes a long time to write a book and
i expect like 50 people to read it and that's
my expectation and maybe my expectation will be
beat but i'm asking somebody to not only take time
out of their day but a lot of time to read a book
so i don't have any expectation i don't know
what people will i didn't write this from
a marketing point a genre point anything like
that it was just an idea and i ran with it and
and the weirdest thing is i i listen to the
book i have the program read it back to me
so it's sort of like an audiobook being
read by a robot and i listen to what i wrote
and then i hear what's wrong with it and then i
can go back and change it that i never would see
if i was just just reading and even if i was
reading it loud i wouldn't catch it like that
can you tell us more about this book that you're
writing joe yeah it i had an idea about a guy
who was burying things in his backyard and i had
an idea of what he was burying and that was all
i knew so i had to write a story around around
the idea and uh i've never written a book before
i have never written what a character has thought
ever because you can't write what characters think
in screenplays because they have to say it or
it's got to be a voiceover and i've always been
of the anti-voiceover school although i know it
comes in handy it's really lazy screenwriting
sorry um but to being able to get in the
head of a character and and be able to like
essentially be in the middle of what is what would
be a scene and then jumping into this giant sort
of exposition flashback thing and then go right
back into the scene afterwards that's really
hard to do on screen uh like that you can't hear
what other you know what one character's thinking
these little tiny things that you can throw out
and also it's just fun to play with words and
and try to find you know i go through and i'll
i'll catch myself saying a phrase more than once
because i'm only one person and i only have so
many phrases but i'm going through and i'm like
yeah i said that i've already said that i can't
use that little linguistic thing again um so it's
it's a lot more solitary uh than screenwriting
because i think it takes longer depending on
the screenplay but i think writing book
takes longer and it's also harder to
you know it's always hard to get somebody to read
your screenplay and give you feedback it's really
worse for a book i planned on paying
an editor a friend of mine who
worked as a journalist went to school for
journalism had offered to has offered to
edit it so he's editing it so i'm lucky in that
regard um because he's really a stickler for
all the grammar and all the things and all the uh
and he goes every through everything four times
until he finds it but um and i the graphic
novel i'll put out uh next month i guess at
the rate it's going and then i'll put the book
out next year 2020 i'm guessing unless something
i'll put the book out in 2020 unless uh
something changes and things always change
how do you plan to write a story you
make a big mess and then try to pluck
the good stuff out uh i sit down
with a legal pad and i write down
little tiny bios uh lines um basic stories
conflicts secrets all that kind of stuff and i
don't like like it's not neat like there's circles
and lines and scribbles and stuff text out and
and i only use one side so i just keep going and
then i will go back through and okay that's kind
of interesting that's sort of good that's kind of
interesting all the stuff i'll get to and i no lie
have stacks of yellow legal pads that are from
projects and like with the vampire mob i had to
i had to i never plan on writing how the main
character became a vampire because i wanted it
it was the screenwriting thing of starting as late
in the scene as you can so i wanted to start after
he was a vampire when his mother-in-law moved
in for eternity i thought that was more fun
so in the vampire mob issue 2 i have a little
10-page mini comic that is the origin story
of the main character so this is him before
he was a vampire and why he became a vampire
and it was something i never shot before and so
i'm writing the comic book and i go back to the
legal pads from 2009 2010 and i'm going
through and i'm like oh yeah that thing that's
where i'm going to go and a boom just found
a way to do it and it was literally a line
that ended up in season one uh that was
something about doing the whole light at
the end of the tunnel thing and i'm like
what's in the tunnel what's in the tunnel
and that was enough to just go so i
think when you're building a story it's
you're you know your character has to want
something out of obstacles and all that stuff
but i also think like you have to have fun making
the character do stuff like it's the old get your
character in a tree and throw rocks at them
um like this should be fun for the audience
this should be fun for you this should be
fun like if it's drudgery like i never felt
like a drudgery when i was writing except for
one screenplay because it wasn't my idea and
sorry to interrupt interject but you said
secrets from your time as a private investigator
did you start to realize how important
secrets are to what makes up a character
what drives people i guess when i worked as
a private investigator i had to call people
pretending to be someone who didn't
exist using a name that wasn't mine
calling from a company that wasn't real
with a story that was completely made up
so i could get information social engineering
social engineering so that is a hard thing to
teach someone how to do and i almost think it's
kind of him like you have to learn in the trenches
um so i i guess what i learned being a private
investigator was it's like being a con man
it's a confidence game so i could change my
voice change how fast i talk change my tone
i would always say my name the company where
i was calling from because if you give all
the information out front then they're
like okay and then you start giving them
the [ __ ] and then you start throwing them what
i call misdirects which are questions that you
do not need the answers to because you have to
stack up the conversation to be thick enough
to not have those questions light up like why
is he asking me this because it's like oh all
these other questions and oh this thing
just dropped you drop it in and you kind
of ride the conversation like a wave and you
just drop stuff in and sometimes you're like
i gotta force this wave and sometimes
it works and sometimes it doesn't but i
am a really good liar i guess and i and it was
storytelling i was telling people stories i was
making up you know i had my lines down
and sometimes you know people would come
back come at me and i would have to come up with
another story on the spot and be able to cover it
so i was i was investigating a guy who was in
court with the client so i we used to call these
cases uh the crazy [ __ ] because this is a crash
and burn you go in you either get the information
or you don't this guy's in court he he's gonna
know most likely that you are calling from the
other side because he's in court so i call from
the other side got a great thing and this guy
starts slamming me he's like what's what's
the phone number i give him the phone what's
the main number for your company i don't know the
main number how do you work at a company not know
the main number uh sir temp i walked in there
this morning they put me down in a cubicle i'm
sitting down i have this phone number right here
so what i need to do is get off the phone with you
get on the phone with my manager ask him what that
phone number is and then i will call you back with
that number is that all right sir yes so i hang
up i call another investigator here's the deal the
name of the company is this you're my boss this is
what we do click call the guy back okay sir here's
the number oh you know i'm just in the middle of
this whole thing with lawyers and i just thought
you're one of them what did you need to know
blah blah blah gives me everything i need to know
because the suspension of disbelief is a
real thing it happens in the real world
so they suspend their disbelief that i'm not who
i say i am and they give me information that why
in god's name would i be asking that so the story
so you have to know who they are to figure out who
you are because you've got to figure out some
something that is either not symbiotic at all
or potentially symbiotic because you
need some some reason it's either
i need something from you maybe you need something
for me we're going to help each other out it's
social engineering having been on um i don't
want to say that side but having been aware of
of some of that and now we're in this new age of
people's secrets coming out and it's instant on
on social media do you feel that that's an
integral part to doing a backstory on a character
yeah i think the when i was working as a pi i knew
people would google and i knew that we needed to
keep track of all the pretext to make sure nothing
got burnt so if a pretext gets burnt it means they
somebody has figured out exactly what
happened they know exactly who did it
they knew they were lied to they know they
know the whole deal and they go online with it
then that's burnt you can't use that anymore
that story's garbage now because somebody else
is going to google it and they're going to find
it so now you got to change up your names you
got to change up your your story now what was
the question so just secrets being an important
part of a character's backstory and a character's
motives and a character's arc yeah i think there
are things about uh like characters in vampire
mob even the characters in play shorts the other
series i made that i know about them that nobody
else knows and no one else will know like i know
there's a big overarching thing with vampire mob
and i know what it's about and no one else does
and i know what the end is and i don't know if
anyone else will ever know or need to know but
i wrote i wrote an hour and 15 minute third
season screen time so i'm translating that
into comic books so i have i have a lot of stuff
written that's already done so i have all these
secrets that i'm getting to sort of drag into
more stories and some that we haven't that we will
learn actually so you think that's okay to do with
characters to how the writer has their secrets in
the back pocket they have their own file on them
so to speak but the audience isn't privy to that
that works yeah i think i think the audience the
writer needs to know more about the character than
the audience will ever know or could know because
you're not going to have the time to explain all
this [ __ ] about them so if you have you know uh
i can't remember it was a psychology thing of like
where you are when you're 16
is pretty close to who you are
most of the developments happen not that there's
going you know more education changes maturity
all the rest of that but the baseline is about
there at 16. so if you take your character to 16
if everything's there what
happened to put it there
so it's literally just going back and okay well
if they're if they're doing this and they're in
this kind of job or in this kind of situation then
they most likely came from this kind of background
that would bring them into this world how and then
you sort of reverse engineer it and then go back
because sometimes i think my mistake was not
knowing enough about characters when i started
writing stuff i knew like i thought i knew bare
bones about the character and i needed to know
way more and i and i don't mean you have to like
write an entire bio but you need to know a bunch
of stuff about these people because when you're
writing about them and they're saying something
and the other character says something and
their response is specific because of who
they are specifically because the secret you know
it's fuels that response if you don't know that
and maybe it will come out in the screenplay
or whatever the presentation you're using but
it's it's the work that actors do when
if i give an actor a screenplay they have
a script and they have the words the saying they
sort of know the situation maybe they ask a couple
of questions but then it's going back to they
have to create that character what kind of shoes
do they wear where you know where did they grow
up what kind of school did they go to you have to
all the stuff that's not going to be on
screen because it will show up on screen
both in writing and in acting there's something
about the grounding of a character knowing
you know where do they live what you know what
does the room look like that kind of stuff
do they have books on the shelves do they not
have books on the show do they listen to music
uh were they ever involved in a crime all this
stuff and it just builds and builds so you have
and and you need that for everybody your minor
characters need to have some interesting stuff
going on otherwise they're just window dressing
and they're not that you know especially when you
have minor characters who are so interesting
they're almost more interesting than the main
character and you're and they're only
there for a little bit of time to make
that happen you need to know a lot about
that character the character's got to have
something going on maybe they have the secrets
that the the person's looking for um i just
if you're not writing something and it's fun
if it's not fun you're writing it it's not fun
why are you writing it like if it's if okay i'm
writing this i don't enjoy this at all i'm hoping
it sells when it sells then maybe i'll start like
liking writing like that's a horrible plan that is
you better like writing because you're going to be
doing a lot of it and a lot of it is not going to
be seen a lot of it's going to get rejected you
are and also you're going to write i know i've
written some stuff my first book will hopefully
be better because of all the other stuff i've
written but it's still not going to be the best
book i've ever written because it's my first book
but i i i know their screenplay structure in it
i know like i can feel like i can feel the first
act i can feel this is kind of what puts this
into place here's the sort of midpoint here's
the big second act plot point now we're just
putting everything down and and it's so great
writing without a budget i don't have to shoot
this i don't have to find this location i don't
have to figure out somebody who knows how
to use drones like you know it's so much
easier when you're just like oh you know what a
house it can be whatever kind of [ __ ] house i
want because i'm not gonna [ __ ] find it
because i'm not gonna [ __ ] shoot it yay
that's a nice freedom to have but also when
the audience experiences that story when you're
reading a book you're in their head in a different
place than when they're watching it on screen
um most likely they're not going to jump
you know when they're reading the book
oh you know that's probably not going
to happen they'll do that more on screen
they might go oh my god but it's not going to
be that that visceral you know when you see an
entire movie theater jump at the same time that's
not going to happen if they're all reading a book
what do you think the audience
wants from a character
i think it's different for every audience um
because we are at an interesting point in history
um and the world seems a little extra dark
um maybe we don't need more dark stories
or maybe we do uh i think there's something you
know i people go to scary movies to be scared
because there's not enough real scary stuff in
their life now there's a bunch of real scary stuff
so i'm wondering if they still need that scary
thing especially we need to go to movie theater
to be scared which is scary just to go to the
movie theater at this point in history um i think
they i think people need characters
who are inspiring but not in a uh
quote way not in a self-help way not in a
hero but you know some small cat like i love
um characters who are in episodics who
you get to see go through a bunch of stuff
and because it's such a long movie it's an 18-hour
movie so you get to see them go through all these
different things that you wouldn't if it was
in a much shorter amount of time and then and
because now you're fed the whole here's here's
the 18 hours here's this whole season go watch it
and then you watch it and they're like so how much
longer for the next one three years what the hell
but you'll wait cause you binged you were
into it you were there was nothing else it was
just you and those characters and on that trip and
and uh and it was fun and now you want to see what
happens to them in the future i think that's uh
i think yeah
comedy is going to be more important than it
ever has been um and it shouldn't be looked
on as being frivolous just because
dramas are seen as more important
comedies uh help more than dramas do uh i
think because we need way more laughing now
than we did before and not the drama doesn't
have a you know you want to get lost in their
world and cry your brains out great but i think a
lot more people are going to be looking for comedy
so we want something in a character
that we can kind of like latch onto
whether we see ourselves in that character whether
that character is classically good or bad right
and do you think that's why big little lies was
such a there was such an appeal because at first
you just kind of saw them is these women that you
know oh you never saw the show okay all right but
i i guess what has what i've always wondered was
why do people have an interest in spending time
with a hitman like i wrote a story about a guy
who kills people professionally that's his job and
people like him like his character
is likeable at some degree
the sopranos yeah it's i mean yeah it's always
godfather all of the mafia stuff that's always
been there but it's but when you break it down
when you actually like go bird's-eye view like
why am i so interested in this guy who runs
a crime family who has anxiety attacks like
yeah and why and why am i going to watch it
when it's on on sunday night at the right time
like that that is um that's never you know that'll
never go away martin scorsese's got another one
on deck and it's you know i think the crime
stuff is never going to go away procedural or
procedurals have never gone away and it seems like
there's even more now people love the crime stuff
why is storytelling important to you i guess
i feel like some degree it's um a service
um not like a like a car repair service but you're
you are in service to storytelling whether
it's you know nobody starts and makes money
so or few people do so if you're telling stories
then it's because you want to like you would
you're spending time with these characters and
building this world without most of the time
without anyone watching without anyone seeing
and so you're alone with it but you're making
it to give to other people so it's a service you
are at the service of the reader the audience the
whoever is experiencing whatever you're making
and whatever medium or media as the case would be
so i guess it's important to me because i feel
like i'm helping a little bit um for what what
do you have stories gives people somewhere to go
away from all this [ __ ] from to suspend their
disbelief to go hang out with a hitman who's a
vampire and drive around and kill some people
that is an escape for people it is somewhere to
go it is suspension of disbelief stories have been
around since the beginning of time because that's
what we all sat around and did because it was
really troubling wi-fi when you were a caveman and
so people were telling stories and drawing stuff
and and then it's you know then it's just verbal
then it's just one generation telling the next
generation telling the next generation
until you start writing that stuff down
so i and and stories are man you can get people
killed with stories you can change people's
lives with stories you can a whole country can
believe a story and and do really bad things
and have been done yeah yeah storytelling is is
really powerful that suspension of disbelief thing
the real world uses it all the
time it's not just for storytellers
what about if a writer says storytelling for me
is a selfish uh motive is a selfish endeavor and
i make no apologies for it i love creating other
worlds it doesn't even mean i need people to love
the story i just love to be yeah that sounds
fantastic but that storyteller's the whole not
needing any one thing is then no one's gonna see
your [ __ ] man you're you're just gonna type in
just like i'm just gonna fill up hard drives with
stories because i love it so much and i'm so great
really are you just waiting until you die and then
someone's going to publish all your stuff and no i
i think that person's if maybe if that's what
it takes for them to be able to write great but
the reality is if no one sees it then you know
like screenplays are maps for movies they're
not meant to be read they're meant to be made
so all the movies that i have written so far
have not been made and will not be made and
that's okay that's uh some of them are bad,
a couple of them i'm probably going to adapt
into books because they were fun to write then
and they would be i think more fun as a book and
i wouldn't have to deal with trying to get it done
and also if i was to make a movie it would be
indie and i know what it's like to be crushed by
production i would never
make a movie at this point
just because i can't do anything
else when i'm making a movie
i know people have made movies it's two years
pretty much at least all the time full time um and
and it's really expensive and it takes a
lot of people and it takes a lot of people
who have to stay with the project it's really
hard to keep people motivated when they're not
making a lot of money and most likely i'm making
a movie where they're not making a lot of money
and then after i have that movie made
then i have to get people to watch it
and all of that seems like too much to do for me
for the amount of time i've got left on the planet
and for what else i think i could
achieve in the same amount of time
and also i could make a crappy movie so i'd hate
to spend two years making [ __ ] do you think a
storyteller is lying to themselves or in some type
of delusion to think that they just want to write
for themselves and they don't need an audience
i mean you can write a blog and not show it to
anybody you can write books and screenplays
and never show them to anybody but then
what do the if if no one sees
them then they don't exist
you're you're just you're creating something
in a little silo that no one's ever going to
be inside of and if i think to some degree
you need to suspend your disbelief that you
know someone's going to make this i can see it on
screen i'm at you know i think you need to do that
um i interviewed derek haas and i'm
blanking on the other writer it's a
writing team i interviewed them a long time
ago for some organization on stage it was a
writer's thing and they had told they
just had a movie come out and they were
driving around with the producer and they were
popping into theaters they were just sticking
their head in and they were just spending like 10
15 minutes watching the audience watch the movie
and then they would get back in the car go to
the next theater walk in do it again and they
kept doing that all over town and i and i thought
and so when i started the interview when i told
them everything i said i want to start with
that because i think that's the thing that
when you're just typing it's hard to imagine
and i always did it would be so great to
um you know have a company just they give you a
check and then they make the story and it's good
and then people see it like and i always
imagined that but i also imagined it when the
industry wasn't what it is now and you know mark
scorsese's on netflix so like i keep thinking uh
people are like you know you can make it moving
around so i'm like yeah martin scorsese couldn't
get his movie made so he went to netflix that's
why he went to netflix he couldn't get his movie
made martin scorsese with barbara tamiro and
joe pesci couldn't get his movie made without
pacino couldn't get his move so i should
do what now i should make my own movie and
maybe maybe go to netflix and maybe go to them
that's great you know amazon studios ted hopes
running that thing they're making some good stuff
i would definitely try to work with that guy
um but i don't have a movie in me anymore
not gonna happen it would have to be
i know what it would take and i would not put
myself through it i think that's okay to be
there because if you know how expensive how time
intensive also you can put that movie out there
and then that's it but also i like i also don't
know what what story i want to invest that much in
like that much time that much money that much and
and it's and i know from vampire mob it's really
hard to keep people attached to a project
um and if you and if the ball gets rolling
and let's say one of your cast member
dies and you're in the middle of the movie
what do you do then you know what do you do
when one of your cast members has a family
member who dies and you stop production and then
you gotta bring it all back up and then match all
the continuity and that's a lot i mean i know this
is a film channel film and screenwriting yeah but
there's something to be said for having a book and
having something in your hand something tangible
sure and i think maybe we'll go back to that a
little bit i don't know maybe we won't but i just
i miss that and i know right now i'm not able
to read so i think that's okay if you're saying
i don't want to make a movie right now but
you still want to write you still want to
tell stories whether it's on instagram i mean i
think that's wonderful i've got 38 short scripts
written done for placer it's ready to roll i
guess in terms of it's not that i don't have an
energy it's that i don't want to spend the energy
on one thing like that's a big thing that's going
to take a lot of time it would have to be a
story that i was on fire about to to make and
when vampire mob was over in terms of it being
a live series i started play shorts and i put
my producer hat on and the weakness in vampire
mob was all the actors like i needed the same
actors to show up and if somebody did not show
up then i had to write a reason why they didn't
want to show up and then bring somebody else
in and whatever else with play shorts it was
uh it's uh episodic it's it's um anthology it's
two actors one story one genre then it ends
then there's another one two different actors
different story different genre than it ends so
and they're all running like about 10 minutes-ish
and they're all really simple just two people
talking sometimes guns get involved but most
of the time it's just two people talking and
that's that is a lot easier to um mix and match
with you know i had one situation with play shirts
where i had a cast i had a location i tried to
schedule it for six weeks the actors could not
couldn't come up with dates and i was just
like all right six weeks is long enough for
me to keep scheduling we're done i was just
like sorry everybody i'm gonna shoot something
else because we can't seem to find a date and
life's short i didn't say that but life is short
so i had another story in another cast in three
days and we shot the next week so um be willing
to uh uh pull the plug on stuff don't be afraid
to walk away from stuff sometimes it's sometimes
it's better to walk away than there's been stuff
that i've been like ah i'm just gonna put up with
more of this [ __ ] because it's gonna eventually
lead to some nothing else and uh and it never did
ever it was just [ __ ] you talked about endings
where does the story begin for you how do you
know you have a beginning of a story when you're
sitting down to write or you're at a coffee shop
i i think it ideas kind of just find you and track
you down and and um and sometimes they've run away
i i think with like bob berry's things it was
just a guy who buries things in his backyard
and i knew what he was burying his backyard and i
didn't know why so the story was why for me so i
didn't know if i so i didn't have the whole
thing at that point and then when i cooked it
i came up you know beginning middle and end and
cooked up other characters and then started diving
in i want to know enough where i'm going but
not so much that i'm not going to have any fun
you know if i outline the crap out of
it then i'm just like i'm just typing
what i did in the outline all the fun
was in the outline i want to just like
bare bones outline just here this happens and
this happens and this happens okay and then i
can make everybody talk and have fun hit those
points it's a lot easier to to do it that way
but i don't know how i i don't know how i know
if i have a story i think it's it's um i don't
know it right away um with clay shorts i wrote
a bunch of those at a theater in santa monica
um and four yeah in four hours so i had to write
that to be ready to be rehearsed and then be on
stage in 10 hours so i had four hours to write
they had six hours to rehearse and then it was
on stage twice so i did that like 40 times so
if you do that enough then so i sit down i've
got two people i know who they are and i don't
have their resume i just have their headshots
so who are they what do they want what do they do
what do they want from each other i would cook the
whole thing and i'd watch the other writers and
the other writers were tapping away like right
away and i'm with a legal pad like for an hour
like this and then oh and then about this and then
once i have it all i'm like okay so without that
and that all right and then i always start typing
because then i wouldn't have to rewrite it because
i think when you start writing before you have
the bare bones of it you're just making a big
mess for you to fix like no lie i made a big
mess in the book i wrote the book i was close
to where i knew the ending was starting and
i'm like something doesn't feel right i read
the entire book and there's a big dead spot
and i'm like this is but this is a red
herring this shouldn't take up this much time
so i cut and paste just that section i
put another document it was 14 000 words
i cut 11 000 words out of it and they're gone
they're nowhere else in the book they're gone
because they didn't need to be there but i didn't
know that until i could see the structure and i
knew this little part of the story didn't need
all this [ __ ] but i didn't know it until i
saw it was kind of like you know if i wrote
a screenplay and i had a bunch of scenes and
that's kind of dry the movie kind of drags
at this point can we just cut these scenes
it's that kind of thing but you don't
know it until you've got it built
and you can't have it built until you've built
it in your writing and it just goes up and then
when it's done you're like oh the windows are
all in the wrong places you know then you got
to move it around do it again is that why riding
on a legal pad for you is like a better process
because you're okay with it being messy right
there yeah yeah and then when it goes into sort
of type format you want it to be more in line and
it's like a signal to you well i think it's it's
um it's kind of it's not to make it sound all like
but it's kind of like sketching before painting
you know it's kind of like let me draw
this out see what it's going to be
now i'm going to put paint on the canvas so
if i if i know the bare bones of the story
and i write with just the bare bones
then other ideas are going to come in
other things are going to happen sometimes
i will find that my bare bones are wrong
and that maybe i found a better bare bone or maybe
i find that that bare bone there was one thing in
in bob berry's things it was actually part of the
11 000 word thing that i it was great you know
i never got to write like this it was like oh wow
i'm writing well i'm going to describe every inch
of this room you guys are going to know everything
about this [ __ ] it's going to be great and then
i'm like yeah this is just way too much it's way
too much you don't need this but you have to have
some kind of fun writing it's got to be some kind
of like it's a like i enjoy it i never it's never
hard i mean it's sometimes hard to get going but
i 20 minutes i look at the first 20 minutes as
warm up like i am i don't just sit down and
then oh what am i doing okay i open up i kind
of look at stuff that's the great thing about
having the program read the book because then
i can sit back and have it read the last chunk
back to me and then it kind of gets me into the
wrong then sometimes it'll i'll hear it say
like i use the word dome way too many times
look at the dome like five times i'm like why
am i saying dome so much for someone's head yes
and i'm like an insider dome
outside a dome over a dome
honest dome top just dome dome dome
i'm like i get rid of these domes
but it's uh but you don't know until you you have
it um and and again maybe it sucks sorry what was
the name of this program uh scribner oh okay i've
heard of that yeah yeah okay and so it will then
read back to you what you've typed oh and it's a
monotone sort of yeah it's a voice it's just yeah
they they have put in breaths oh nice so you can
actually hear the robot taking her breath here and
there and i think it reads um things in quotes at
a slightly faster pace than the other stuff so for
dialogue i think it does speed it up a little bit
but um yeah i definitely caught stuff that because
i remember having i always had table reads of
everything for vampire mob and i would record it
because i would always catch stuff when i listened
to the recording and then i did one i had a
screenplay called sue happy that the filmmakers
alliance um did a reading of and they brought in
they had casting director they brought in 25
actors it was a giant ensemble thing it crushed uh
and it was the only time i ever got to see one
of my screenplays like almost brought to life
like it was a staged reading but um but it's that
is the reason i think that that'll be the next
book because i know i know what that story does to
an audience so i know what it can do in book form
do you have a ritual for like okay you've
copied up you're you're waiting is there like
this ritual to listen to the scrivener notes
yeah uh well one thing i i always listen to
this i have a 9 i have an 8 hour and 49
minute long playlist of fats waller songs
that's why i wrote a lot of songs um and i have
been listening to that for over a decade um
because it i know all the music really well
so i don't listen to it but it occupies the
part of my mind that can think of something else
to do so i always have that on and only i had to
change to tool the band tool for a sequence
i was writing and i just like i couldn't get
it with fat's waller i never had any problem and
i'm like i need something a little i'm like tool
and it was perfect it was exactly exactly what i
needed but uh yeah coffee water make sure to drink
water everybody it's important and um headphones
and i always write at home i never write in any
coffee shops or anything like that just because
i can close out enough the world with loud
headphones and i have tinnitus so i always hear
ringing uh 24 hours a day seven days a week so um
when i have those on it there's something about
1930s music that that hits the frequency that
buries my tinnitus a little bit wow except
for when maynard sings i don't know well
there's one tool song that's a little much better
don't they have a new album yeah fear inoculum
as to the pixies oh that's great what makes
a great story joe what makes a great story uh
i think i like roger ebert's uh take on it it's
when you don't remember where you parked your car
i think that's really good yeah when you're in
when you're in the theater and you're watching
the movie if you don't if you can't think
where your car is parked that's a good movie
and i think uh for a story it's
different for everybody i mean
my wife watches stuff that i don't watch and vice
versa and uh she loves the historical drama stuff
and i'm not so much with the historical drama
stuff um but she and she's like it's just like
candy you know it's you know it's romance and i'm
like okay that's great i don't want any candy i
guess i don't but like i watch bob's burgers
i love bob's burgers i think it's a great show
and it's really just a dysfunctional family
it's all like every other classic sitcom in
the history of everything and they just have
a more grounded take than the simpsons on
that genre was the brady bunch dysfunctional
the brady munch on screen i guess technically
sort of not not like now i don't know because
really was really the beginning of like anything
close to truth getting on television so good times
good time yeah it was great all the normal air
stuff and they recently did a live reading or live
reenactment and they built the sets and uh jimmy
kimmel had them do an episode on the family an
episode of the jeffersons and they had to bleep
part of it because you can't say that word on
tv anymore and to hear all the stuff that rgb
bunker said that you can't say on tv anymore and
maybe it would be more useful to hear it on tv now
so people could understand what a bigot is right
out of the gate that's a good point because it
was such a great dynamic of him playing off for
getting me rob reiner's character as the meathead
yeah and and this politically active outspoken
young person against this old school bigot and
then you have the the codependent peacemaker edith
you know who just wants to make a map and the
thing is if you watch that show there are episodes
that don't leave the living room like that is
doesn't happen a lot there are a lot of shows that
do that like barney miller was one of those shows
that you know you'll have more than one you'll
have the work set and you have the home set
on all the family was pretty much just the living
room in the kitchen once in a while you'd see a
bedroom maybe the front porch and then maybe
go to the jefferson's once in a blue moon but
almost all of it was like a stage play what about
welcome back cotter did they leave the class yeah
they did oh they did oh yeah here and there they
did yeah because i think they did the hallways
let's go back through all the seven issues
uh but i think barney miller was
genius just in terms of the setup
because you have because and that's sort of the
way i thought about vampire mob was that if you
have kind of like a few main characters and
you rotate in all these other characters you
can build a really big world and it's also a lot
easier to schedule because if you can you know i
was having actors come in and do four hours so you
would write so they could get what you wanted done
in four hours and then if you can set it up so
they're doing more than one day in the story day
then they can show up in more than one episode
and it changes the dynamics of the whole thing
what was the first story that you ever saw i
guess television or film or even that you read
where it lit a an idea sparks an idea that this
is what i want to do i want to tell stories
you know i never thought i would
wanted to do any of this stuff
i thought i was going to be a photographer and
never thought i'd write a story or anything ever
i did i watched a ton of tv as a kid for some
reason i knew some tv terminology i knew tag
as a kid i knew the tag in a sitcom because i
watched a lot of talk shows and heard people
talking about sitcoms and said that last thing at
the end is called a tag that you do and i'm like
oh cool and so i'm like an eight-year-old going oh
that's the tag dad oh good i don't care um but uh
i was i guess i was just sort of
aware what interested me was that
barney miller in was in new york city and all
the family was in new york city good times of
things for chicago um taxi new york city taxi
was new york city i always thought i was going
to live in new york city growing up i thought
it would be a divorce man living with another
divorced man trying not to drive each other crazy
but uh perfect strangers no no that's uncoupled
but i guess i was just so
aware that they were shot here
as a kid like i would always watch it all the way
to the end because you were waiting for the next
show to start so you'd see every single credit and
then you'd see shot at abc television studio or
cbs television studios and i'm like so all of that
is not a new yorker when you're a kid it's like
you know especially when when i'm an hour i was
growing up an hour and a half north of new york
and i'm thinking oh barney miller he's just down
just down the train ride down in new york and you
sort of think of it that way and then you think
oh so they have them all there and they're in
california where it's sunny and they're pretending
all this oh that's interesting joe we have a video
we'd like to play for you okay cue it up here
los angeles is a [ __ ] million communities
saying independent storytelling is one thing new
media is one thing web series is one thing it's so
[ __ ] stupid there's no mainstream in independent
within those categories is a billion subcategories
and i'm a tiny little fragment of nothing go go to
my imdb page there's nothing there i'm nobody but
the audience who knows what i do that's who i'm
somebody to and that's who i all i [ __ ] care
about because i don't yeah i don't get i don't get
hired by the audience and fired by the audience
we have a i tell stories they help me tell stories
pretty easy business plan again not for everybody
sponsors you know they want that number awards
they want that number but audiences they just
care about stories even even if you tell stories
with actors no one's heard of is it a good story
how many stories have won oscars with
completely unknown casts unknown directors that
[ __ ] happens it's not just what's number one at
the box office it's not the number one rated show
you know again arrest development family guy these
shows that got cancelled and are now coming back
after years of an audience build that's the matrix
that's the thing that we can we have over them we
can tell a story worldwide we can keep going
we don't have to have weekly ratings we don't
need to hit box office we don't need to think
about that we don't need to think about awards we
can change the rules change the way things happen
and not emulate all these past systems new game
new way to do things new systems new validation
systems all new individuals we each come up with
our own way to do it our own individual business
plans we don't need validation from anyone other
than the audience and you don't need that much
validation as an indie storyteller to keep going
because if you're looking for an oscar jesus
you better [ __ ] be eating carbohydrates every
goddamn day because that is a long run and it's
and it's an empty errand i'd rather i'd rather
entertain real people and hear from real people
than please some unknown body of whatever so they
say good job [ __ ] that's not real that's
not human at all let's start with a fork
that was uh shot courtesy of nick's coffee shop
great place great setting i love that we still i
don't know this was in 2013 i believe so this is
kind of cool to see in that setting and um i know
they were very generous with you to let you shoot
and do different things what's your take on seeing
that video where you were just your thoughts
on creating stories i guess uh i guess it
was right about all the stories that were
coming because now there's a billion of them
um i guess i think the the thing about um audience
like now that i a bunch of time has passed
like i have i've met so many people internet
neighbors who have helped me tell stories at
knicks and other places um that's like that's why
the audience is their neighbors i think that the
the what i was saying about talking to
the audience i've been talking to the
audience for years and so when i'm telling
a story i'm thinking about people i know
who will either see it or read it and it's
you know not know like you know no no but
as far as you can know people on the
internet that's why the term neighbor is
i don't know it's friends is a little strong
i think and neighbors is a little more like
you know you have neighbors you're friends
with your neighbors but that's that neighbor
friendship where you're like you know you don't
want to get in each other's business too much
but everybody wants to get along it's
like that kind of thing and i think with
people that you know on the internet it becomes
sort of like that and and it you build the social
media neighborhood that you want to live in if
you don't want to hear about all the bad stuff
then you filter all the bad stuff and block
those words and then twitter can you make a
list that is exactly people who don't piss me
off that's a good list to have make that list
so you can go on twitter just look at that list
nothing bad's happening on that list it's all nice
but the next thing that i when the book comes
out and when the graphic novel comes out
because i've been talking to the audience to
my neighbors in my neighborhood all this time
it's inherently different than if i was just
filmmaker in marketing mode on social media
and all i do is talk about my project me my making
a film my my going to a film festival here's the
next project blah blah yeah people are interested
in that but i you know people know my cat
because i post my cat all the time and
does it have anything to do with filmmaking
no do people have cats yes do people i
started a band with my cat called mike and me
we don't make music because i don't know how to
play any instruments and he doesn't have a thumb
so two of them even so we just make the album
covers and and it's entertaining it's amusing
so when i show up with something that's like
meaty like here's a book then they're gonna be
like oh you wrote a book cool joe wrote a book
this guy that i've been talking to for years
so different than hey anybody want
to read this book anybody anybody is
now marketing now i'm advertising now promoting
before it's just my neighbors hey you guys want to
want to come over and see something i'm um i made
i'm going to project it up on a sheet on the wall
that's pretty much what it feels like and that
you can fit a lot of people in in that room on the
internet with that sheet on the wall because it's
on the internet and it again your stories can last
like uh i can't remember somebody told
me oh i know it was um rupaul had a
has a game show i guess i don't see it but has
a game show and i sold a jar of celebrity air in
2005 it was a jar of air that was captured within
proximity to brad pitt and angelina jolie at the
mr mrs smith premiere and made international
news it was on access hollywood jay leno did a
bit about it it was gigantic and somebody sent me
a screen grab from rupaul's show and the question
on the bottom was did someone sell a jar of air
from brad pitt and angelina jolie and it was you
know it was like last year and so that was from 05
and so the i can't remember who told me about it
when he sent me the screen grab he's he said i
said i'm amazed that people still would even care
about that because angelina jolie and brad pitt
they're over and he's like clever is forever oh
and i'm like clever is forever i like that that's
really good so i think that i think that you can
as an indie make small stuff that is clever
that maybe people will look at down the line
i made a point to not put references to current
day time i didn't want to use any current slang
i didn't want anything that would date it so
i made up my own slang there's references to
man there's references to happy days there's
references to it's a wonderful life like i
pulled slang from everywhere because of that
now it's its own world it can't go bad there's
no reference to anything because then people go
oh i remember when that happened oh this is old
and if they never reference anything there's
no there's no date on it you don't know
they never say that's why i think you know the
advantage to telling stories in the 80s now is
because nobody had a cell phone so you can't text
now all your plot holes so many plot holes i just
text yeah the whole show's over because it's the
80s and i i have this and i shouldn't have this
i can just i can oh you want you need to talk
to somebody across town like okay as opposed to
driving to their house oh they're not here you
stay here and wait and then i'll go and then
totally different story cleverest firmer joe
do you still believe that there will be blue
collar storytellers or have they already arrived
i think they're already here i think uh i think
that it's because whatever everything that's
gone on online there is not um you know it when
there were less movies being made they were worth
more money for everybody and there were also less
jobs for everybody there's never been more acting
jobs in the history of everything than right now
there's never been more writing jobs than right
now there's never been more directing jobs than
right now there's never been this much stuff made
so i think there's a ton of opportunities you know
in the industry because there's so much being
made and when there's so much being made
it's a mass is inherently blue collar it's not
white color in that white color like directors
you know directors are sort of the white color
worker when you when when there's 50 of them
now it's just a bunch of people who direct stuff
so when you have all the tv shows all the films
all the stuff that's online add up all those
jobs add up all that you know again the the
guest star emmy consideration performance number
was 2 800 and something so there were that many
performances to consider so when you're in
the thousands just for an emmy consideration
just to get the nomination and
that is only getting bigger
there is no there the star system the you know
there's not going to be the star directors
there's going to be like a billion sort of
smaller known directors but i don't think
there's going to be you know martin scorsese
i don't think that's i think it's going to be
less of that because there's so much stuff i
think you know there will be voices that will
be you know distinct and original and different
and there'll probably be more of those
voices because more stuff's being made but um
because it's just like bird's eye view in the 70s
you made a movie that's what people did there was
nothing else to do you went to the movies or you
watched one of three networks or you read a book
read a magazine went for a walk that was it now
i can sit home and watch the history of film
on youtube if i want it is ridiculous
how much stuff is online so saturation
naturally displaces special so special is is you
know stars and that kind of thing blue collar is
like there's a ton of people doing these
jobs now so to be famous to be a star
i don't know there's famous people
but there's also a lot of famous people we don't
know because we don't watch that show and the
show's been on for nine years but still i've never
watched big bang theory still haven't seen it no
idea don't care and just like there's sort of
this middle class squeeze you know especially
you know last few years in the us do you
think it's the same with artists there's
there's the blue collar artists and there's
a whole bunch of blue collar artists and then
there's the white collar ones and very little
middle class or i'm just making this up um i
yeah i don't i think would be more like
middle and then upper like i sort of feel
like if you're if you're working in the
industry and you know making a living uh
you know most most of the people who work on stuff
are not you know again it's a temp gig it's a temp
gig and then when that temp gig ends you got to
get another temp kick so you can pay the mortgage
and if you don't get another temp gig and then
you don't get another temp gig after that and then
months go by then that's a problem um but i i just
i think there's going to be less stars more famous
people not as famous um because i've never i i've
never seen this many actors in my life i've never
even off the top of my head even knowing just
think of just the tv shows and movies you've
seen in the last year so much more than what
would have been watched in previous years because
the delivery system is the internet it's what
everyone else is doing it becomes habit then
we're talking about it online it becomes
behavior and that was the thing when you're
trying to get people to change their behavior from
watching a tv show at a certain time on a certain
day and then you were getting changing their
behavior by here's the entire season watch it
and then that behavior changed like all the ten
years ago all the web series people were saying oh
yeah five minutes is too long five minutes is way
too long no one's gonna watch five minutes no one
has time to watch five minutes you're an idiot if
you're making something it should be three minutes
that's how long as much time people have and and
and they were all wrong uh yeah some people want
to watch three minutes but in terms of like an
overarching philosophy on human behavior no wrong
what human beings will do is sit down and watch
12 hours of television because it's brand new and
they want to be able to talk about stranger
things at the office on monday new behavior
so remind me again what a blue collar artist is
blue collar screenwriter blue collar director i
guess blue color is is uh less known less you know
more scrappy not necessarily scrappy i think it's
literally just from saturation because in the 70s
if you had the number of movies that came out in
a year and the number of tv shows that came out in
1975 and you added them all up and now everything
that came out in 2018 and you added them all
up it would be a skyscraper and be a little too
two-story building here's 1975 here's now
all these movies and tv shows and actors so
when you have this much i'm a director really
what did you direct well it's only this much
because it's 1975. it's not that hard oh
you directed something what did you direct
everybody there's a lot of stuff to pay attention
to when there's a lot it becomes less special less
valuable less less it becomes less because there's
so much you don't feel like it's it's like the kid
who has one toy and the kid loves that toy because
the kid only has one toy and then there's the kid
who's got aunts and uncles who has been burying
that kid and every toy the kids got every toy none
of them are special because there's a million of
them you only have that one that's special so when
you have you know a handful of people who were
allowed to make movies and that could now it's
that it's a bigger pile of people there's
way more and it's less precious it's less
special you know honestly no one gives a [ __
] about the oscars not that they really gave
a [ __ ] that much before but if you look
at the reality of box office oscars are not
catering to the public they are catering to
the academy because when the streaker came by
well that was too good but i mean they were
streakers yeah but but that idea of you know
the oh it's an oscar winning
special you know it's it's scarcity
there isn't that scarcity so if it's not
scarce if it's not special if there's so much
then it's it turns into blue collar it turns into
a lot of people are doing this at the factory
they're all making these things so i mean blue
collar and they may make a living that is white
collar they may you know their job maybe you
know maybe they're not dragging cables around uh
and that kind of thing maybe they're
doing something you know nicer but it's
less special and i think it's good that there's
that that happened i think it's gonna i think it
will make the industry better what about if people
say well why should i bother i'm not gonna stand
out is standing out at an archaic it's constantly
yeah i think it's standing out your goal then
or my project's not going to stand out well i
mean sometimes good projects get buried you know
it's really hard to control the world and what
you're doing you know again the movie was recently
buried because of all the mass shootings because
they knew marketing wise that was a bad move um
if if you can as a filmmaker storyteller artist
whatever it is that you create if you can
find five people who like what you do and
you talk to them on a regular basis and they
tell other people about what you do then that
audience grows and it grows naturally grows
organically grows slowly and the quality of the
that group of individuals who knows who you are
that changes i think what you make and i think
it changes you because you know kind of who it is
that's going to be looking at your stuff because
you talk to them on a regular basis like i know
stuff about people and people are going
through stuff and they're internet neighbors
you know i know more people online than i do
offline way more they're all over the place
but it's um
and i do you know the we're all famous to a few
people thing is is the reality of saturation is
how many people does it take for you to be famous
how many people have to know who you are to be
famous the weatherman in minneapolis is very
famous in minneapolis he's going to walk into an
applebee's and everybody's going to go the weather
man's here that guy shows up and here nobody gives
a [ __ ] they don't know who he is because he's
famous in that little group the little silo it's
like like the huge band in the uk right now that
none of us know because we're not in the uk but
they're huge over there wolf alice i don't know
but that's what i mean there's always one yeah the
little silos you know all the korean k-pop stuff
all that that is another silo right uh i do a
live streaming music show on wednesdays and
people stay up i'm amazed like netherlands
uk like it's two o'clock in the morning we
do one show and so people make requests from
essentially when they tweet a youtube link
with a hashtag all i do is follow the hashtag
i click on the youtube link and i play their
request and then everyone listening votes
and if they don't like the song then
i stop the song so it's called song
request cage match so it's like yours bring
your song and see if it gets beat up or not
and so in australia someone requested something
and there was another australian who's also
on and the two of them are going back and forth
about the song and they're going on and on and
on about it i'm like i've never heard of
this song i have no idea who this guy is i
know and they're like oh it was everywhere and
that's what i mean like those little tiny silos
of you know it's like the people who are really
into game of thrones and people are really into
one particular comic book that nobody else you
know and if you're not into it you don't know
about i was at a barbecue and some guy walked
up to me it's like hey do you watch game of
thrones i was like no all right i can't talk to
you do you watch game of thrones and i'm like
i'm not going to feel bad because you want to find
something to get all excited about the finale with
but that's those silos so when somebody says
hey have you ever seen the seen this vampire mob
thing well that was vampire mode this
thing just watch it's hard to explain
that's them telling somebody else about your
work that them saying i like this i think you
might like this that is the best marketing in the
world and you can't make that happen you can't
force that to happen you can't just show up and
crowdfund and make that happen and you also can't
show up on crowdfunding and then never crowdfund
again and then and disappear seen that i've bought
literally while i was looking up a documentary
and i tripped over some segments of it on like
vimeo and i went back to their twitter and i and
their twitter literally was we've reached our goal
and there was one more tweet and they never
tweeted again and i was like wow that is some
hardcore opportunistic crowdfunding because you're
not even going to say anything past the we hit the
go we're out do they make the film it's not
out parts of it are out um it's been too long
i'm guilty of that myself with
one of my crowdfunding things so
maybe something went wrong but uh yeah that's
that's that's bad filmmaking that may not be
actually shooting but if you are
going to crowdfund and then stop
talking the day you make your goal or the day
after you make your goal you're doing it wrong
you need to keep talking those people forever
because then it's going to come out then you're
going to do something else and i've i i've talked
to someone who is a big supporter of mine who has
contributed to everything i've ever crowdfunded
for and she told me that of a couple of people
who i know online who she had contributed to and
she said you know i never got any of my perks
ever from any of those projects you're the
only project that i've always got my perks from
and i'm like really and she said yeah i don't
want to you know say anything but they show up
and ask for more money and they didn't give me
the perk from the last one that's bad filmmaking
sorry because you're doing it to make films
and if you're crowdfunding and then you do that
you're screwing over your audience you're
you're not authentic you're ingenuine you are
you're exploiting people you're
taking advantage and you're an [ __ ]
what's something about storytelling you wish
that you had learned earlier in your career
or you wish you'd stuck your guns on maybe people
tried to talk you out of it i guess i wish i knew
how much how much more important character
development was to writing i think that was
i don't think i developed the characters enough
when i started writing and i think that's where i
if i had if i'd known to take more time to develop
the characters i think i would have less or
would have had less of a challenge in either the
writing or the rewriting especially the rewriting
because i think when you you've got a draft you're
going through it you're looking for the problems
you see the problems and sometimes the
solution is in the bio of the character
it's something that you you haven't put
on the page but it's something about them
and and and so the answer is already there because
you did your homework before you start writing
the script so that that's one thing i wish
i knew and in terms of sticking to my guns i
when i i have i probably have
stuck to my guns to a fault um
i i'm one thing i'm really
bad at is tolerating fools
and there are a lot of fools uh in
the entertainment industry in every
industry but i think more in the entertainment
industry special breed of fool um in what way
um i guess because they're there's very little
much like people call themselves experts and
the only thing that makes them an expert is that
they put the word expert in their bio and there's
no you know it's not like you get a doctorate
or something you know you say like i'm a social
media expert really that so you must spend all
of your time learning about the new social media
thing to do and that's all you're doing um going
off on a tangent i it's a good tangent yeah um
well you said sticking to your guns to your
detriment you don't think that that's a good
thing sometimes when you're the writer you're
the employee and sometimes uh i have not often
not that many gigs to begin with but a couple
of times i was writing something that was stupid
and i knew it was stupid and but the people who
were producing the project who brought me on
had success previously and and they were
convinced this was going to be their next one
and and i was the guy to do it and and it was a
horrible idea that i explained to them what the
why it was a problem and the chara the main
character wasn't likable in a way that would make
the audience would never make the audience care
about the character and so i had to cook up like
this whole other thing and then explain to them
like we this we need to root for the character and
if the character is um i remember whoopi goldberg
told the story of writing a screenplay about a
hardcore right-wing republican senator who finds
out that he has black blood in his lineage and
all of his politics would make that bad and
uh i can't remember who she went to for advice
and the person gave them the
advice yeah just throw it out
uh and they were like this is a great idea we have
a lot of interest and people are yeah who cares
who cares what happens to this republican guy he's
a bad person who discovers that he's an even worse
person like why are we going and and the these
two producers their argument was well you know
bill murray in groundhog day he's very unlikable
i'm like yeah yeah your main character is female
so name me one mainstream comedy that has an
unlikable female lead in the history of film
and nobody could come up with one because it
doesn't work you have to have there has to be
a reason and and bill murray is bill murray so you
already have you know that character if that was
an unknown and being unknown with all unknown cast
that movie would be a harder read because he makes
that character fun and likable and another actor
might not be able to do that as well um yeah and
and the thing is it was it was a horrible idea and
to the best of my knowledge it's never been made
not surprising so you're saying that working
on characters flushing them out backstory
was something you wish you had learned earlier
because you said before that you would go on this
legal pad so that mount that must have been well
that was something i learned yeah when i first
the first screenplay i wrote was based on a real
life situation that i cooked the story around it
wasn't comedy and it wasn't i was based on a hit
and run that i was stopped from photographing by
the police and it was a cover-up and so that the
character i it was all plot it was no it was very
little character and and it was a just a house of
cards plot too because that's what you know when
you build up this sort of mystery and and you have
this house of cards and you like oh i need i need
to change that one thing because that's not gonna
work and then you realize that that is connected
to all these other things and i'm like oh if
i change this and i have to rewrite everything
that is a nightmare if i had the characters
already cooked more then it would be i think
easier to go into the character bio and the
character mind and look at the plot from that
point of view rather than being sort of like
god here's the plot here do something come on
character do something it doesn't work so it was
something i learned and that's where the legal pad
came from because then it was like i can
scribble i can write whatever i want now
this matters no one's ever going to see this
and that's the other thing to keep in mind
is when you're writing no one's going to
see until you show it to them enjoy that
but we want to show it to them oh you want to
show it to him but enjoy it when you have it
because when it goes out for notes it's something
else and then it goes out for more notes and
and it gets torn apart and it's only yours when
you're writing it and then you give it and then
it gets and it comes back and you write it
and glue it back together and how's this
do it again until everyone's
happy most likely except you
at least that's been my experience
how long have you been in los angeles 22 years
and in a couple of months a month
a couple months i'm leaving forever
not by choice but uh some family members
need some help and my wife and i are going
to be that help so i'm leaving los angeles
the place i've lived the longest actually
my whole life so how does that feel to you
do you is it sort of like you're seeing those
years flip by in your mind like a tv show
like it's i is a combination of uh regret
and uh i think kind of the realization that maybe
things not working out for me in the entertainment
industry maybe was for the best uh because i
think the timing of how if i if the success
came the way i thought it was going to come at
the time that i thought it was going to come
when spec sales were huge and
people made money fast i uh
i guess i i feel like i've just gone
through like the longest training program
anybody could ever go through to learn how to do a
bunch of [ __ ] um i didn't know how to direct or
write or act or do stand-up the
way i do now from having done it
sitting down to write a book having done
all these different things made the writing
easier and better and and all that
stuff because i've been doing it um i
you know i i wanted to come here and
be successful and buy my wife a house
didn't happen so when things don't
work out the way you want then you
improvise adapt and overcome and
that's what i'm going to do moving
to albany new york which is not a
entertainment capital that i know of
but locations will be easier to get i do have
a line on actors uh placer which is something
i can continue doing uh graphic novel has
i don't know how many more issues in it um
i guess i had a lot of fun i met a lot
of people uh some of it was not fun
but uh i guess overall i wouldn't have done it any
other way because i had to know like i had to know
what was going to happen you said regrets earlier
oh yeah what were the regrets
oh god too many to number uh
i guess i should have
tolerated some fools more and
yeah a bunch of stuff but aren't you glad that
forgive me i don't know where you were before
you went to boston yeah okay but were you still
in uh what if you had stayed in upstate new york
and or gone back i don't know you know what your
travel line was and you worked for a company
and they pushed you out the door because they're
hiring people from oh sure somewhere else or
they're closing that plant or something so that
essentially happened to the company uh that i
was working for in boston i was very lucky that
the company i had a day job with in boston had
a company out here so when i i said i'm moving
to los angeles if you guys want me that's where
i'm going to be and they were like you can work
in the other company's office for boston so i
had a job that i flew with so that was great
um and then they pulled the plug on the
company fired everybody once i got out here
um but what was the question so i guess the
question is what if you hadn't come here
wouldn't you be more regretful for had not
because you're you're still with your wife
oh yeah i'm not trying to get too personal but
i mean some people don't oh yeah every time all
the time you know what i'm saying i'm i know
people have died you know in pursuit of this
uh some people died from suicide some people
died from drugs overdose some people died from
lifestyle you might say and
uh i guess i guess what i
didn't know and there's no way you really
could know like i did stuff in boston and
it you know it was done live there's no you know
this video of it but most of the time it was like
it was theater it was something that was done
for a live audience and that's what it was meant
to do and then when it was over it ended and that
was it it didn't exist anymore except for in the
minds of the people who saw it i've heard from
people who remember the stuff i did in the 90s
when i was in boston uh performance art
stuff installation art and like all that
stuff is gone none of it exists anymore uh
but they remember it and you know if you
make a movie and it's successful and a
lot of people see it and they'll remember
it sometimes movies become a part of people's
lives they buy the dvd they watch it on a regular
basis uh something on the background it's the
movie they go to when they're feeling bad uh
that is uh something i sort of got to experience
with vampire mob that you know i did have people
contact me who said that they you know life
wasn't great and they were kind of down and
they enjoyed the humor and the characters and the
story in it and it gave them some place to go for
a while and that's why i feel like to some degree
storytelling is a service you are in service
of other people stories are for other
people and that's who you're creating for
i mean you could create for yourself but
if they don't see it then it doesn't exist
what do you think that you should have tried
more of or maybe maybe there's nothing you know
i changed directions a bunch of times uh when
things weren't going right i'm like you know
when things with acting and stand up weren't going
great and i was looking at writing screenwriting
and i hadn't written anything and i'm like man
do i have a learning curve and i'm like i gotta
back up everything else take classes really focus
on on screenwriting and and learn everything that
i can about it and i've lost the question again um
what do you think that maybe you should have tried
i guess
i probably should have um
i think i should have kept doing
stand-up i think i could have should have
kept spreading myself out then the way i was
and find uh finding ways to deal with that chaos
which i enjoyed to some degree um but the
more i met a lot more people doing stand-up
um and when you're a writer you meet less people
because you're at home writing and i was in a few
writer's groups and there were always a nightmare
i just it was almost like competitive notes like
oh yeah you didn't like my screenplay
wait till i give you notes on yours
it was garbage i remember one screenplay that
this guy wrote and had very specific terminology
to the x games to all these special things you do
on a skateboard on a bmx bike and all this stuff
and i'm reading it and i'm like yeah i don't know
what any of this is and he's like well that's the
language that they use that's the thing i'm like
yeah but what does that mean what does they what
do they do well all you have to do is say that and
people know what it is yeah but the person at the
reading the at the studio the agent they're not
going to know this oh i'm sorry i'm telling you
information you don't want to hear i can oh
so this isn't feedback you just want to be
you want you just want to be told this
is good you don't want to make it better
you just want to so then and
then when it was time for my
my screenplay to be read he just was like
anything he could find and and you you know
i know what good feedback is and what is not
good feedback and that was revenge feedback
what advice would you give to
someone else leaving los angeles
hmm i wouldn't give them any advice i guess uh
yeah i kind of uh
sometimes advice is uh
just someone else's version of the way they
think things should work and and it's just uh
it's just another obstacle it's just it's a it's
a your expectation is being managed by someone
else's experience and their experiences and
necessarily what's going to be your experience so
the advice has no value because they're well the
way i did it well yeah the way you did it is and
and that was i think one of my problems was that
i was trying to i saw how other people made it and
i was trying to do it the way they did it i was
okay so you do this and then you win a contest
and then you get a manager and then you go out
take a script out and then you sell it and uh
there's a million ways careers happen
and don't make the mistake i did of sort of
telling your story you're like well this is
going to happen then i'm going to do this this and
this and this and that's the way it's going to be
and then when it's not oh i did something wrong i
guess i'm the problem so i gotta change the plan
so i'm not gonna do this this and this and
all right that's not working i'm gonna it
i i enjoyed less of it i missed out on a
lot because i was working so hard to try to
make it what did you miss out on oh birthdays
vacation seeing the outside world friendships
a lot a lot
you can only sit in one chair at a
time what does success look like to you
i don't know anymore actually
that is a good question
nothing to do with the entertainment industry
well you'll still be able to make stories oh
yeah and and now you might have a pool of people
that oh sure aren't going to be you know
there's going to be access to talent up
there as well yeah and maybe something new will
come from it and it'll be a new definition of
because i think coming being here we're so
clouded by not the middle class version of
success oh yeah but this like astronomical
thing that i don't even know if those people
are happy we don't know that we don't know
if that's i have met a lot of people who were
wealthy and successful and miserable i remember
talking to somebody who had they were working on
a basic cable show and a network show at the
same time and they were complaining that the
basic cable show didn't send a driver and then the
network show did it was you know why doesn't the
basic cable show sent to driver and i was just
like i'm in the back of my mind going you know
how many [ __ ] people would like to have that [
__ ] problem not having the basic cable show send
a driver oh you have to drive yourself to your job
that you could poor you you're bricking my heart
it's like listen to people who like social media
experts who complain about traveling they're like
oh my god it's so hard to travel from conference
to conference and miss flights and all the rest
of it really get up on a roof and do some roofing
in august in los angeles get the smell of tar up
in your nose and then tell me how hard it is again
to sit in an airport really is it really that hard
to sit in an airport sorry sorry you have to sit
so long sorry that's such hard work for you sorry
you're not at the hotel where you're supposed to
be at the right time again get on a [ __ ] roof
in [ __ ] august with a smelly tar in your nose
and tell me again how hard it is that you work
writing's not hard none of this [ __ ] is
hard none of this [ __ ] is roofing in august
in los angeles anytime you
think you're working hard
think oh well you know what i'm not on a roof in
95 degrees with tar up my nose that's hard work
all the rest of this you know i worked hard but i
didn't do roofing for the last 22 years you know i
was indoors it was not hard work i've seen artwork
i've been about hard work i've done hard work none
of this [ __ ] is hard work hard work is a bunch
of 18 hour days on set day after day after day
that is hard work hard work gaffers do hard work
electricians do hard work carpenters do hard work
actors less so director's lesson so i never wanted
to be a video village director i never wanted to
be the guy sitting looking at [ __ ] monitors and
barking [ __ ] from a chair i wanted to be holding
a camera and i wanted to be right in there with
the actors because that's where it is happening
and if i didn't know how to run a camera then i
couldn't have done that so i learned how to run a
camera so i can do that and i'm a better director
because i run camera because i'm there i'm with
the actor the actor's looking at me the director
who's operating the camera that's pointing at them
completely different experience and the guy
over in the corner who's barking stuff back
or gets up walks over says something walks back
i just yell cut good anything all right again go
i can shoot 10 pages in four hours door to door
in and out done it every time every episode of
play shorts was four hours rehearse the actors for
two hours a week before bring them in we walk into
knicks at four o'clock we set up lights we eat
dinner we shoot we close it up 9 9 30 we're gone
four or five hours all you need don't eat an
18-hour day and you don't need a giant crew
any thoughts on um friendships in la partnerships
friendships in l.a are sometimes friendships
are based on projects there's a lot of project
friendships like you work on a project and
everybody's friends and you can know each
other forever and then the project is you never
see each other again uh that's pretty common and
then you're right it's like co-worker friendships
it's that kind of thing um i think it is harder to
have or at least it was i found it harder to
have more meaningful friendships just at the
the pace of everything that was going and
everyone's so worried about their career and
and who's got what who's doing what and the next
thing that it it um didn't allow for a lot of uh
um deeper friendships i felt but some
of that's me so and some of that delay
so is it about the work for me it was always
about the work i really you know i really loved it
and i wish i could have done it more but
i didn't
what's the thing you're most proud
of the thing i'm most proud of
nothing that's on screen i don't think
i'm i think i'm more proud of what i
what i knew
that i got through it
i guess not any specific work it's sort
of the all of it my all those classes
workshops and writers groups and meetings
with managers and contests oh christ
i could have made a lot more
money doing something else
but it wasn't i moved out of here
for the money because i was doing
you know the non-profit art thing in
boston and there's something about the uh
there's something about making art when you
know it's not going to make you any money
that is different when you know i mean people
oh i paint and i put up in a gallery and
people pay me thousands of dollars yeah most
painters don't have that most painters are
they got a lot of paintings and
that haven't sold and i think
when i did an installation that had uh 27 tvs in
it and uh things were run by motion detectors and
there were vcrs and slide projectors and took up
a giant room and it took me 50 hours to put it up
and i had help and i was in that gallery for a
week and almost slept on the floor one night i
was there so long and i knew i wasn't gonna make
a dime from it knew it knew it cost me money to
do it knew i wasn't gonna make a dime but i
had to do it i had to do it i had to make it
i it was the first thing i ever made it was huge
and uh i showed it once i never showed it again
and that thing changed everything if i didn't
do that thing i wouldn't be sitting here talking
to you right now because i know the dominoes
that went over because of that one thing i made
so
when you make something that is for
commerce that is that is the goal
commerce is the goal and it doesn't
sell then it's not a success
and and that is it's a business that is
people don't get paid if you don't make money
uh art is you know i got grants i got you
know i worked at day jobs to pay for all the
stuff so i could have the time to make the
art um and all the and the the reward was
seeing people go through it hearing from
people afterwards like that was enough and
when i started doing stand-up and performance art
and dealing with doing a little bit of touring
with a [ __ ] with two different shows um
i that's when you know i got things got to get
paid for you know i got to pay for all this stuff
so this has to make at least this much money to
pay for this much stuff and if i'm going to get
in if i'm going to get paid it's going to be
above these costs they when you're out here in
los angeles in the entertainment industry you're
not making anything that is not made for money
um that is the goal that's it's a business you're
not making art you're making commerce you're
making product and yes there's some creativity
in it but if nobody wants it nobody wants nobody
cares well you've written a great screenplay
that no one will ever make that no one wants
there's lots of people who have i've
done definitely done a couple of those
but uh so the value of it
is like screenplays are not
to be read they're maps for movies if
they're not made into movies then they're not
then they don't exist they're nothing they're
not there's screenplays literature there's not
people sitting around hey we had a good screenplay
yesterday it's so good that's ridiculous um but
the i think the thing with the internet
neighbors who have a response to my work
is similar to seeing human beings have
a response to my work in a gallery and
i started as a photographer so
it was just a picture on a wall
or in front of them or in a newspaper magazine
and then when it was installation i surrounded
the viewer sound light images physical
objects um a structure that changed the space
and then i started doing performance art
because the same thing i could control
i they were sitting there i was sitting here
and i could create something that we could
all that could have we could it could happen
together and you would experience it your way
and and i'm and we're all here together this
is what's happening and yeah you paid a ticket
to get in here but it's barely going to
cover the cost of doing this [ __ ] show uh
that is very similar to when i make shorts and
i put them online and i hear from people who
who saw them it's the value the value is the
experience that you're creating for someone
else in whatever media so you know stand-up
comedy your job is to make people laugh
so that's your job if you're telling somebody
a story it's a funny story not a funny story
it has to keep them amused and engaged
and interested and when it's uh
art i think you don't think exactly the same way
i think it's i think it is a little more of the
uh i'm making art and you're gonna see it and
the relationships i think different a little
bit yeah just thinking of like cindy sherman
you know and and whether i mean i know she got
a lot of criticism for some of the work that she
did but i just found her so fascinating yeah
yeah just just especially the time in history
that she was doing her work compared to now when
everyone's taking selfies left and right right
right such a weird and also just the reality that
people are more comfortable in front of lenses
there's going to be entire generations now that
have no problem being in front of the camera
or just living for life in front of the camera
not even being able to enjoy an event having to
show having to document it yep selfie museums
and that's all cool that's great but at some
point you're not really in reality though right
people are going to movies and they're texting
during the movie why would you pay for a ticket is
it for the air conditioning and somewhere to sit
right and that and and and that's what makes
going to the movies unattractive to people
like it has to be marvel
it has to be loud in action
so everyone's attention is on the screen and not
on the other screen they have in their pocket
and if the movie's not good enough to keep your
attention from texting then maybe it's not moving
or maybe
we need more it's like a drug and so what it's
not enough to just have good dialogue anymore
a great interesting scene between two people we'd
become too desensitized to it well i don't know
if all of us have but i think they're definitely
you know there's it's like pop music pop music is
inherently bad music not all of it but a lot of it
except for the song pop music that's actually good
so pop music is you know it's it's uh it's short
it's catchy it's got some part that you can sing
along with or come along with or whatever it's got
some little chorus hook thing in it someone's been
jilted yeah exactly and i think it's i think
it's the same to some degree with with movies
uh that are popular is that you know it's just
meant as this little thing that you see and it
comes and goes and and that's it it's very and
then there's other movies that maybe have a bigger
impact um i don't know i really think about the
audience audiences now so many people are watching
stuff alone you know with a laptop or on their
phone or you know if you're on a plane everyone's
watching a movie on something and that is the
more normal behavior now than to have the sort
of communal experience at a theater where
you're you're all laughing at once or you're
all jumping at once and now it's just you and i
think as a storyteller i like now i never think
about a theater i never think about a group of
people watching i always think about one person
yeah i never think about a group i used to think
about groups of people when i was writing and now
i think about one person especially writing the
book i definitely think about one person because
that is the only way it works but even with yeah
even with the other stuff i would say that's true
what are things you learned in the
last five years that you wish you knew
the first five years you were here god
i'm thinking of all these negative things
uh uh let's see uh it can be reality
based it doesn't happen people lie
and you will be amazed at how much they
will lie who they are when they're lying
and what they're lying about um five years
ago i guess i didn't know how much of a
an impact i've had a tiny impact i've had on a
bunch of people i know online um i didn't know
i don't like the term influencer and i don't
consider myself an influencer because it sounds
really let me come and influence you just um
and not the c word either not the secret content
creator yes but i uh yeah i think that's one
thing uh so people lie you didn't know the type of
impact that you had on people that were let's say
well even online even like doing the film courage
interviews you know seven years ago and then i
pop back in and read the comments and i'm like
i did why said what i did what really well that's
i'm glad i inspired you but man um it's very nice
but i didn't know i could do that uh ever
um so i guess that would be a third thing um
i don't know i did not know
how [ __ ] up the country was
like i i was always you know uh painted
as a pessimist when i pointed out the
things about the country that seem so obvious
now that have always been there but yeah
um i guess last five years i think
that's three and a half months i guess
i didn't know that people would like my cat
so much online i don't know that's something
i didn't know that i wish i knew i would have made
my cat much more of a prominent figure in my work
but it's cool to see sorry to interrupt
but the two of you together though it's
not just your cat i mean mike's adorable and
he's great you know he's takes a great photo
but my photography professors would be like
what are you doing like literally i remember
one class he was like i do not want to see any
pictures of cats or wrought iron fences those
are the two things i do not want to see in this
collage and now i'm just taking cat pictures um
but it's the two of you together you did something
about like investigating some kind of catnip ring
oh yeah which was hilarious oh yeah you were
like it was like sort of investigative journalism
and it was like i don't know if it was like
bad catnip or what it was yes but you were you
were on it yeah um this guy i know that lives in
glasgow scotland had a fake news show and he had
uh reporters uh all in different countries
that were all doing stuff and so i came up with
uh i was using the opioid epidemic but i
just switched it to catnip and then made
everything about catnip and tried to interview
my cat yeah that yeah that was a lot of fun
i guess i wish i knew how much more
important having fun was like it didn't
s fun doing the work like like i know
i've never had a bad time directing
like even when it was things didn't
go right it still was really fun um
i really like working with actors so i always you
know run quick easy fun sets it's you know there's
no [ __ ] there's no man there's no [ __ ] not on
my sides at all um and i guess the other thing i
learned is that sometimes i probably learned this
before five years ago but sometimes somebody who
is hungry and wants to work on something is better
than someone who has a resume who can prove they'd
be great to work on it sometimes i've definitely
worked a couple of times i've worked with people
who uh it was their first time shooting
something it was my first time shooting
something and none of us should have been
shooting that and it all worked out fine
like it was just like i was not gonna i
need a dp we have to have a director of
photography there's no way that we can
shoot this without i was just more like
so you can focus right you know you could shut
a couple of things with your dslr okay can you
do this can you do this can you and it worked
out perfectly it was odd that we ended up with
three access to three five ds three uh
operators and we had three identical lenses
that were um it's a 28 to 70 uh l series lens that
just gorgeous just does great stuff and somehow
one person had another one one person
could borrow one and so we had matching
cameras with matching lenses for the whole
shoot it's the only thing i used 2870.
quote from you it's all about the audience when
you tell stories to agents managers and producers
that doesn't happen i guess the way audiences
experience stories just like uh regular people
uh you know they have emotional response
there's disbelief is suspended um
when you're telling a story to people in
the business they're it's it's almost like
everyone in the industry is a magician
and you have a magic trick and
they all know already know how the trick works
because they're they work in the magic business
and so they always look at tricks like a magician
not like an audience member and so your agents
your producers all the rest of it they can't
experience it the same way because they have been
paying too much attention to how tricks work
that they can't suspend their disbelief and just
see the trick and go oh wow how'd you do that
the marketing part of like if you're writing a
story and it's a really good story and it is um
not marketable it's probably going to be harder
to get made um if something is marketable and
it's a good story it might be easier to get made
but i think i've made this mistake sometimes i
think you can be too focused on trying to write
to the market i think you can be like a friend of
mine who's like all into whatever the new thing is
that people are into and they will then chase that
genre um and it's i don't know it seems like an
empty errand to me it seems like you're you're
chasing your tail because if you can recognize
a trend then it's already over because by the
time you're jumping on that trend it's it'll
be done and like when i i wrote a vampire show at
the height of all the vampire [ __ ] uh not out of
marketing just out of well if everyone likes these
vampire shows and i don't like any of them um
can i have one that i like and so that was that's
vampire mod vampire mop was a show that i would
like uh and i and it people continue to find
it and and it also i think people's perception
changed because there aren't a million vampire
stories now so when they see vampire mob now
it's different than it was ten years ago and
that's kind of cool like time changes the story
what do you need right now what do i need
right now hmm uh patience time and cash okay
in that particular order
maybe well yeah probably yeah
mostly in that order yeah it takes a lot to pack
up 22 years of your life and move it 3000 miles
i did it i was in boston for 13 when i moved down
here so and i you know i couldn't i threw a lot
of art away i couldn't take all my installations
i couldn't take any of it no way and i couldn't
store it because i didn't have the money
so it i literally threw art in a dumpster
so i could move here that'd be crazy if somebody
found it and they still have it in their apartment
you never know it's true it'd
be weird for them to have it
what do you think you needed
when you first came here
in 97 98 you said 1997. um i don't know
i don't know i think uh i would all
i was looking for was some kind of
validation that i was doing the right
thing i think and rarely if ever got it
i think the that is also kind of a wasted you
know it's great when people like your stuff
and just people in the industry like
your stuff it's very nice and sometimes
they uh maybe you like it a little too much um
how's that possible uh because they're trying to
sell you on how much they like it so they need
something from you no it's more like they're
it's they're telling you
how great you are sometimes
not everybody but i've had a few times
where um i'm trying to zero in on this
and i lost it is it because they want
to be cast in their next project i mean
like when a manager talks like a lit manager
talking up talking up your project to you to
try to essentially don't believe the hype
like sometimes had a couple of managers who
and that's part of their job they want to
keep you psyched and that's nice but try not
to believe the hype whether it's your the hype
that they're they're like hyping you they're
they're like it's gonna do this and just gonna do
that and you're you know and that's all great but
if you really believe it uh you're going
to be greatly disappointed and i think
that's that's the hard thing when you're you know
when people move out here it's like you know you
give up a lot and the industry becomes your most
important relationship and everything that's the
first thought in your head and everything
else comes in second and that's uh
not the way everybody does it that's the
way i did it um because i was just so
i'm like i'm going to make this work i'm going to
make this i'm going to force this to happen and
i couldn't i couldn't force it to happen and
then after a while it wasn't fun and then
when it wasn't fun and i just like i'm just
going to do my own [ __ ] and i'd more maybe more
entertainment industry meetings when i ignored
the entertainment industry than when i didn't
uh because people treat you differently when you
make stuff when you're a writer it's just oh you
got some stuff on a paper good for you isn't
that nice but when you make stuff and people
oh you made oh you're a director oh you actually
wrote and directed you made something people treat
you differently it's a totally different vibe
then here i have this i'm going to make this
so good that's if you've made some stuff even if
it's just shorts but the how stuff made changes
you know changes you as a writer changes you
as a director editor like i i know why i was
rewritten so a lot more having been an editor
and editing my own stuff and watching the actors
talking and i'm like yeah i don't need any of this
is it it's gone because i'm the editor it's uh
yeah do you consider yourself an industry guy at
the heart of it joe i guess to find industry guy
you said you didn't want to make the industry
your higher power but you did for a while
oh yeah definitely and so even though
you're leaving to go somewhere else
yep my assumption is you still plan on being
creative oh that's not going to ever leave you
yeah i've that's hardwired in me i've always
been making stuff somehow forever always
from photography i started taking pictures when
i was like 11 or 12 and had a front page when
i was 15 and that was it i was going to be
a photographer because i had the top flap
of the front page of the kitchen journal and i
beat other photographers out on that thing so
that made me feel like that um i'm sorry i
asked the question again well are you do you
consider yourself an industry guy in terms of
keeping your finger on the pulse of the industry
i've actually been ignoring the industry for years
while i've been here uh i really don't uh i don't
pay any attention to box office i don't pay any
attention to what's new i don't pay attention to
any of it i could be in des moines iowa and do the
same thing that i'm doing now i just need actors
uh i'm sure there's actors in des moines right
um yeah because the ir io sorry writer's group
yeah exactly um so yeah i will always make
stuff i can't not make stuff whatever stuff that
is uh uh living in albany will be different uh
because there's not a lot of people
like me and so i'm you're not gonna have
i'm never gonna hear the word call
back in a conversation in albany
i'm never gonna hear any kind of industry anything
it's just and and it's going to be weird because
i oh it would be weird it'll i'll be a weirdo
because i will be surrounded by people who don't
make stuff and my wife's an artist so she makes
stuff but yeah it'll be a bit of a culture shock
plus the snow so well that'll be worse but uh yeah
i i think the one thing by ignoring the industry
for years um i have sort of preconceived in a way
or or pre-planned in a way how it's going to work
when i'm i'm not here in los angeles because
all the money that comes from crowdfunding
is does not come from los angeles the people
who support what i do are not in los angeles
they're all over the world and
we just meet on the internet so
it doesn't matter where i am because we meet
on the internet that's my neighborhood so
that's where i meet my neighbors that's where
i show my neighbors the work i make so that is
so to them i won't move to most people i'll be
like oh you just have a different background
for the cat pictures but otherwise be exactly
the same you know and i haven't put out
i haven't put a short out in
three years four years now
so uh i have to go to get back and oh yeah oh
no i did collecting all right maybe i did that
right i can't remember when i did
clyde spawning but regardless i haven't
i definitely haven't put anything out in three
years how do you think mike will adjust to the
weather he's gonna hate it is he an indoor cat
okay oh good big time big time yeah yeah but he's
so i mean he hates the cult here he's like
gets under the covers when it's winter
here so he's gonna lose his mind there
i'm sure his fur will get really thick
but that cat has been by my side through uh
the first short i made my first [ __ ] i'm
just gonna make [ __ ] short technically my
second one um he was next me when i wrote it
he was next to me when i cut it and he's been
next to me for all the stuff that i've written
and edited he likes to hang out is
he a rescue uh it wasn't like any
burning buildings or anything involved uh
we adopted them ferment or erect a rescue
i know we adopted them from our vet had a wing of
cats that were up for adoption oh okay and so we
uh adopted them there i consider that a rescue
that's nice it's a nice fit yeah it was really
great it was a really cool setup because
uh we had a camper 18 years named dave and
when dave died we i was like just like like
more than a human died oh yeah and uh so i i i
like there's like how much time do i want to
give you know what's the proper morning time for
to lose a cat and then get another one what's the
amount of time uh three months that's it i'm like
i gotta get another cat and i'd never raised a
cat from a kitten ever because dave was kathy's
cat he was an adult when we met and her previous
boyfriend didn't like cats and she had two cats
and i grew up with cats so those cats were like
my wingmen like they were like we got along great
oh yeah yeah good uh good crew joe what are you
most excited about in terms of when you leave
los angeles going to your new destination
and starting working on something i guess
i'm i'm interested to see what happens uh
with a production i've never i've never
like put a crew together and and actors
any place but here so i'm kind of looking
forward to seeing what that looks like um and
you know when you rent locations out here
or borrow locations or steel locations or
whatever everyone kind of knows that oh you're
oh you're you we should charge you because you're
making a lot of money on this right you're
making money right you got to be making money
and i don't think anybody in albany
new york is going to be you know
convinced that there's some giant
money-making machine behind something so um
it'll be uh i guess i'm kind of looking
forward to being the weirdo i guess in the room